when they started learning languages
myself I wish I'd had a framework of
five seven ten simple rules of thumb to
follow to help me learn foreign
languages you're luckier than I am
because I've compiled a list of ten
rules of thumb to start learning any
language from scratch
[Applause]
when you start learning a language
always make sure that you know exactly
why you started learning that language
that is crucial a lot of people make the
mistake of starting learning a language
without knowing why or maybe they just
heard that that language is cool or
maybe a friend of theirs is learning
that language these are not strong
reasons you have to find your own strong
and valid reasons they're going to help
you keep learning every single day so
one piece of advice is take a piece of
paper and jot down your reasons and you
have to check whether these reasons are
really valid and really important for
you
like in any other field of life we have
a number of false convictions and false
myths that we tend to believe in when it
comes to language learning and in order
to learn efficiently when well and by
yourself you have to get rid of these
convictions in order to do that take a
piece of paper and jot down all the
negative convictions that you have
towards learning let me give you an
example
you probably must have thought or still
think that in order to learn a language
you have to go and live abroad that is
not true or that you have to go to
school so jot down all the possible
convictions and false ideas that you
have in your mind and pour them down on
a piece of paper so that you can take a
look at them and start dispelling them
this is really important to start
learning on the right foot
a very common mistake that people make
when learning a language is to just
throw themselves at the language without
any planning what you have to do is
actually plan beforehand there's a very
simple way in which you can do this just
take a piece of paper
jot down a date of reference and from
that moment on you tell yourself I'm
going to learn that language after that
you just have to come up with two or
three simple goals and you have to ask
yourself this very important question
what will I be able to do within two or
three or six months this in turn will
define the actions and the time that you
will put to make it happen
so for example you might need 30 minutes
a day over 45 or 60 minutes a day this
is really important actually it's
crucial if you want to make it happen
every single day and this creates
continuity and it is single handedly the
ultimate secret to language learning you
have to learn every single day no matter
what you do and no matter your
background experience
[Music]
okay now you have compelling reasons and
a solid plan of attack what is the next
move it is to find good language
learning resources and this is the point
where a lot of people make crucial
mistakes so how many times has it
happened that for example you find
yourself wanting to download a lot of
apps find books and you find yourself
with a pile of stuff and you don't even
know how to start and where to start
here's the catch find just one good
language learning resource and in order
to do that don't look on the internet
but go physically to a bookstore where
you can establish a physical connection
with that book leaf through it smell it
hold it that's the way you can actually
gauge whether you will want to use that
learning resource find one use it and
then move on to something else
this is absolutely crucial
once you have your language learning
material you have to learn how to use it
what is the best method the answer is
there is no one-size-fits-all solution
because every brain is different if you
take a look at successful language
learners they all learn in a different
way there are some things that are
common but their methods are different
so instead of looking at their methods
just take a look at your method start
learning a language and that readjust so
start learning a language and ask
yourself is the method I'm using good
for me is it efficient and is it
enjoyable if the answer is yes to both
then you are on the right track if the
answer is no that is method is enjoyable
but not efficient it means is not good
for you if it's efficient but it's not
enjoyable you have to change and you
have to buy this line and remember once
you've found the method that worked for
you there's no nothing and nobody's
stopping you from learning that language
[Music]
when you start learning whatever you do
remember this very simple rule of thumb
focus 80% of language and 20% of grammar
think about for example a five or six
year old kid they speak the language
without knowing anything about grammar
why because they've internalized the
language through exposure and that's
exactly what you can do as an adult
learning a second language so as a rule
of thumb what you should do is expose
yourself as much as you can to dialogues
and the real language and use grammar
only as a reference so you can use
grammar notes or you can even buy a
grammar book but don't focus on that use
it just as a reference to help you
understand the content of a real
language you expose yourself to when I
uploaded my first video in Swedish on
YouTube I realized from the feedback
that I had gotten that something was off
with my pronunciation and intonation and
I learned an important lesson you have
to learn the sound structure of the
language at the very beginning give it
attention give it care because this down
the line is gonna make a big difference
imagine developing the wrong sound
patterns in the language like tying a
knot the tighter it gets the more
difficult it will be down the line to
undo it the same thing goes for sounds
so remember take the time and put the
energy into focusing how the sound
structure of a language work from the
very moment you lay hands and eyes and
ears on the language this is going to
make a huge difference down the line
learning a language is never ever a
linear process things change down the
path you have to keep this in mind when
it comes to choosing the way you learn
languages so you have to constantly
readjust your methods your approach and
the time you spend with a language
because this is a critical point so for
example in my language learning path
what I do at the beginning and what I do
when I am an intermediate student or an
advanced students is different it's
different in what I do and how I do it
and when I do it at the beginning I use
for example my bi-directional
translation method a method that I use
to translate a language back and forth
in order to understand the basic
patterns of the language but down the
line when I have a better command of the
language I would never dream of using
that technique that would be old
old-fashioned I will use other
techniques to adapt and change my
strategy according to my competence this
is really important to remember so when
you have found a method or a routine use
that routine for a certain amount of
time but remember that there will come
the time to change their routine and
adapt it to your new competence
you see this phone and do you see this
paper these are equally interesting and
effective tools to learn any language
you want now what do you have to keep in
mind is that a combination of these two
things
makes the difference so it's not about
using just paper or using just digital
it's about combining both it is
scientifically proven that when you use
a piece of paper you and your using your
pencil or pen and you're using your hand
you establish a connection with the
words that you jot down with the words
that you see and you have to you don't
have to be at the service of Technology
but you have to make technology be at
your service so technology give you
speed while paper gives you connection
and if you combine speed with connection
that will make wonders for your language
learning endeavors
[Music]
I started learning Romanian a few years
ago but unfortunately I give up after a
few weeks why did that happen when
looking back I realized that the reason
or the main reason why it happened is
because I didn't establish Elin contact
I kept reading books I kept listening to
things but that was not enough for me so
a very important lesson I've drawn for
that is that you have to have a rewards
down the path it's not just about
hitting the books it's about discovering
things making connections sharing laughs
and you have a lot of different kind of
rewards you have social rewards for
example you can have a conversation on
skype or you can meet a person
face-to-face in a bar and trying to
speak that language or you have cultural
rewards reading a book an interesting
book in that target language by a famous
author or watching a movie in that
target language and all these rewards
create a sense of continuity you want to
continue imagine learning a language
like walking down the path you stop at
certain cities and then you take a rest
you get to know people and that in turn
will help you keep going and this is
what language is all about at the end of
the day it is about having experiences
talking to people having laughs
discovering yourself and discovering
others and ultimately it is about
sharing so here you have it these are
the ten rules of thumb to start learning
any language if you want to know more
details and more stories more pictures
and more links you can click on the link
in the description box below thank you
very much
[Music]
you